la presencia de los atletas rusos y
bielorrusos continúa siendo debatida en
las organizaciones deportivas Este
martes la olinland tenis Club confirmó
las nuevas medidas para habilitar a los
tenistas de estos países en wimbledon
para lo que deberán firmar una
declaración personal obligatoria
hay tres partes principales en la
declaración la primera es que confirman
que competirán como neutrales por lo que
no tienen nombre de país ni denominación
de bandera las declaraciones de apoyo al
régimen a los dos regímenes o a la
guerra están prohibidas al igual que los
jugadores que reciben fondos de esos dos
estados o de empresas estrechamente
relacionadas con esos dos estados
en 2022 rusos y bielorrusos fueron
vetados por la invasión a Ucrania lo que
llevó a la ATP a rebajar a wimbledon a
un certamen de exhibición
mientras continúan las deliberaciones
para los Juegos Olímpicos de París 2024
después de que el comité olímpico
internacional recomendara remitir a los
deportistas de Moscú y means la ministra
de deportes de Francia aseguró que
respetarán la voluntad de los entes
deportivos
Francia reconoce Y respeta la autonomía
del movimiento deportivo y en lo que
respecta a los Juegos Olímpicos y
paralímpicos es por lo tanto que el coi
y el comité paralímpico internacional
serán quienes tomarán una decisión
soberana cada uno en su propio campo de
responsabilidad con respecto a la
participación de Rusia y atletas
bielorrusos
Ucrania pidió que los deportistas
declaren públicamente contra la guerra
para participar la posibilidad de que
los atletas marginados puedan competir
sigue sumando adeptos bajo los
argumentos de separar a los individuos
de la acción de los estados beligerantes
y a los nulos castigos hacia otros
países que participaron en recientes
guerras